in the understated style of March in
Dutch politics Mark Rutter drove himself
to the Royal Palace in The Hague to
update King William Alexander on the
collapse of his government pausing to
exchange a few words with reporters
before carry on to discuss a caretaker
Administration with the Monarch Rutter
in power since 2010 is the Netherlands
longest-serving prime minister but this
ruling Coalition has lasted only a year
and a half
it's no secret that the Coalition
Partners have very different views on
migration policy and today unfortunately
we have to conclude that those
differences are irreconcilable that's
why I will immediately offer the
resignation of the entire cabinet to the
king in writing the prime minister
wanted the number of relatives of War
refugees allowed into the Netherlands to
be capped at 200 per month but his
Junior Coalition Partners refused
it's a difficult moment we've held
intensive talks about all sorts of
measures to stop the influx of Asylum
Seekers this has not been easy we also
have to make room for those who do have
the right to a safe haven in the
Netherlands the Netherlands is expecting
around 70 000 Asylum applicants this
year almost double last year's number
and that's increased pressure on the
government from far-right parties like
the pvv led by guillot Builders yeah it
is
the collapse of the government means
Parliament will most likely be dissolved
with the general election expected in
November but the Coalition could stay on
As a caretaker government until a new
Administration takes over a process
likely to take months and Mark Rutter
has indicated he would like to stand
again for an unprecedented fifth term as
leader Rory challenge